Humanity has come to an important decision.
Two futures stand before us.
We can continue on our current path...
...where we rely on outdated electricity grids, inefficient buildings...
...and dirty power plants that contaminate our air, or we can change.
We can create greener cities where solar panels and wind turbines power our homes,...
...where buildings use less energy and save money...
...where our air and water are cleaner, our quality of life is better...
...and our economy is stronger.
And here's the thing: this cleaner, more sustainable future is within our grasp.
To get there, we need to rethink old conventions,...
...improve energy efficiency and invest in green technology.
Most of all, we need to stand up for the future we deserve.
Join us.
It's time to green our cities.